[Aplausos]
[Música]
el día 1 de diciembre del año 2001 es un
día que ha quedado grabado a fuego en la
memoria colectiva del pueblo argentino
ese día el entonces ministro de economía
domingo Felipe cabalo anunciaba la
puesta en marcha de la congelación de
los depósitos bancarios popularmente
conocido como El corralito a partir de
ese momento los argentinos no podían
sacar más de 250 pesos y En aquel
momento 250 dólares de sus cuentas en el
banco por supuesto la reacción popular
no se hizo esperar y durante días las
protestas crecieron sin parar
[Música]
la imagen icónica que ha quedado para el
recuerdo ha sido la de grupos de
personas agrupadas frente a las
sucursales y sedes bancarias golpeando
cacerolas y exigiendo la devolución
total de sus depósitos queridos amigos
amigas el caos fue tan grande que poco
más de dos semanas después el día 20 de
diciembre el por aquel entonces
presidente Fernando de la rúa se vio
obligado a dimitir tras su Natura
jornada de protestas en la Plaza de Mayo
una jornada de protestas que se saldó
con al menos 29 personas fallecidas 20
años después en visualpolitik nos hemos
hecho unas cuantas preguntas Por qué se
produjo exactamente el corralito Cuáles
fueron los verdaderos motivos de la
mayor crisis económica en la historia de
la Argentina y quizás la pregunta más
importante de todas existe acaso la
posibilidad de que volvamos a ver una
situación similar atentos
[Música]
camino al Abismo
sabéis que en visualpolitik nos encanta
la Argentina y qué queréis que os diga
creo que si algo ha quedado claro tras
la ya larga lista de vídeos que hemos
publicado sobre este país con Esteban Ni
más ni menos que 21 es la clara
predilección que la Argentina tiene por
tener un gobierno gigantesco y no no nos
engañemos en la práctica solo Existen
tres formas de financiar un gobierno
enorme una carga tributaria asfixiante
un endeudamiento crónico o una
descontrolada de emisión monetaria Pues
bien a lo largo de la historia podemos
encontrar gobiernos que han tratado de
gastar a mano llenas recurriendo a una
de estas fuentes de financiación Sin
embargo amigos lo particular del caso
argentino Es que desde la década de 1940
prácticamente todos los gobiernos han
usado y abusados en tregua de estas tres
herramientas al mismo tiempo Eso es lo
que explica la eterna crisis gaucha la
madre de todos los males de la Argentina
una constante de todos los gobiernos de
un color o de otro un gasto público
inasumible una política que desde los
años 40 y mira que ha llovido lleva
cosechando los mismos resultados siempre
los mismos crisis crisis y porque amigos
las cartas están sobre la mesa
el problema con la deuda es que hay que
pagarle y refinanciarla y cuando no se
hace entonces la financiación Es que así
hay se encarece luego por el lado de la
presión tributaria sucede tres cuartas
partes de lo mismo al contraerse las
rentas del sector privado la recaudación
termina disminuyendo a medio plazo y
además alienta la economía informal por
tanto a los diferentes gobiernos no les
quedó otra que echarse en brazos de la
emisión monetaria para mantener sus
políticas de más y más gasto público el
abuso de esta herramienta ha sido tal
que ha hecho que la inflación disparada
sea un mal crónico de la economía
Argentina una economía que llegó a
experimentar un proceso de fortísima
hiperinflación entre 1989 y 1990 que tal
y como sostienen los economistas Pablo
guido y Gustavo lachari esto supuso la
muerte del dinero
[Música]
tal y como ya os contamos en un pasado
vídeo titulado cuando la Argentina quiso
volver a ser Rica el único momento donde
se dio sensación de que realmente el
país quería cambiar de rumbo fue bajo
los gobiernos de Carlos Saúl menem quién
de la mano de suministro de economía
domingo cavalo puso en marcha un amplio
proceso de reformas incluyendo la
privatización de buena parte de las
empresas públicas sin embargo sin
embargo lo que no desapareció fue la
madre de todos los males el gasto
público disparado básicamente la única
diferencia fue que en lugar de
financiarlo con inflación esto es
dándole una y otra y otra vez a la
máquina de imprimir billetes los
gobiernos de menem financiaron sus
políticas de gasto con el dinero
procedente de las privatizaciones
primero y luego con más y más
endeudamiento es decir que lo que hizo
menem fue a pagar el incendio de la
hiperinflación de la presidencia su
antecesor en el cargo y dar un golpe de
Timón a la economía Argentina pero no
sacó adelante ni mucho menos todos los
cambios que el país necesitaba para
poder despegar el gasto público siguió
creciendo la apertura con mercosur Pues
fue muy limitada La regulación siguió
siendo excesiva especialmente lo
referente a la legislación laboral
porque para que os hagáis una idea en
Argentina hacen tan difícil y costoso
crear empleo que al final pues
lógicamente No se crea empleo y cuando
lo hace pues lo hace la economía
informal de cajón fijaos como estaban
las cosas allá por comienzos del nuevo
siglo
[Música]
por cada 100 pesos que figuran como
ingreso bruto en el recibo de un
trabajador solo 82 pesos van a su
bolsillo Mientras tanto el empleador por
esos 100 pesos de ingreso bruto debe
abonar 133 pesos esto significa que por
cada 82 pesos que recibe efectivamente
un trabajador privado el empleador debe
abonar 133 pesos la diferencia un 62%
constituye una interminable sumatoria de
impuestos Pablo guido y Gustavo lachari
apunte sobre la economía Argentina 2003
y ojo porque hoy las cosas siguen igual
o incluso peor para colmó volviendo a la
época de menem muchas de las
privatizaciones hicieron de tal forma
que crearon mercados cautivos que se
quedaron en manos de amigos del gobierno
las cosas mejoraron sí pero en el fondo
Pues no tanto así que cuando menen dejó
el gobierno el país seguía teniendo
muchos pero que muchos problemas los
argentinos no lo sabían pero el
corralito ya se estaba gestando
[Música]
diciembre de 1999 Fernando de la rúa se
convierte en el nuevo presidente de la
Argentina la situación económica era ya
En aquel momento complicada era urgente
hacer ajustes por ejemplo para frenar el
agujero que digo agujero el boquete que
tenían las cuentas públicas y que
amenazaba componer patas arriba toda la
economía el Tic Tac hacia la destrucción
económica estaba en marcha y aquí amigos
os hago una pregunta qué demonios
pensáis que hizo de la rúa como quiso
enfrentarse al déficit público
recortando quizás el gasto público
ni de broma hablamos de la Argentina de
Argentina de Argentina la propuesta del
gobierno se basó básicamente en subir
los impuestos en lugar de recortar el
gasto para que os hagáis una idea de los
algo más de 7.000 millones de dólares de
ajuste en el déficit público incluidos
en el plan del gobierno para 2001 casi
6.000 millones correspondían a subidas
de impuestos poco más de 1.000 a control
del gasto es decir en una relación 80-20
Claro que eso no es todo porque una cosa
la propuesta política y otra muy
distinta a la realidad tras varias
crisis políticas en noviembre del 2000
de la rúa reconocía finalmente que la
disminución del déficit no sería ni
mucho menos la prevista y al mes
siguiente para colmo el congreso aprobó
un presupuesto con un déficit de 7.000
millones de pesos es decir para
entendernos un 70% más del anunciado por
el plan inicial del gobierno amigos el
Tic Tac sería en marcha y ya parecía
claro que el año 2001 sería muy pero que
muy difícil
el año 2001 fue una catástrofe la
inversión cayó un 45% el consumo casi un
10 y el desempleo no paraba de subir la
tasa de paro alcanzó el 18% y las
protestas lideradas por la oposición
peronista se recrudecieron de la rúa
enfrentó ocho paros nacionales en sus
dos años de gobierno en los que también
surgieron los piquetes esto es grupos
organizados ligados a sindicatos que
durante sus protestas cortan las
carreteras las calles y la actividad
económica en semejante contestó la
desconfianza era casi total lo que
provocó que los depósitos bancarios se
desplomaran un 20%. nadie se fiaba ya
del futuro de la economía Argentina
había que poner a salvo todo lo que se
pudiera
para intentar revertir la situación de
la rueda decidió colocar a un economista
partidario de ajustar el gasto público
Ricardo López murcia al frente del
Ministerio de economía duró 15 días
amigos al gobierno Ya solo le quedaba
una bala echarse en brazos del padre de
las reformas de la era menem domingo
Felipe cabalo entonces para mantener el
gasto público se obligó a los bancos y a
los fondos de pensiones a comprar deuda
pública al tiempo que se aprobó un
megacanje para convertir deuda a corto
plazo en deuda a largo plazo con tipos
de intereses mayores Lo que equivale a
decir patada para adelante es decir ya
lo veis todo tipo de malabares con tal
de no meter la mano donde hacía falta al
gasto público que esperaban que esa vez
ocurriera algo diferente pues
evidentemente no
[Música]
era una situación imposible el Gobierno
ya no tenía activos valiosos que
privatizar Y lograr dinero La
financiación Internacional estaba
cerrada el fondo monetario internacional
dijo que sin recortes de gasto no
contarán con él y si el gobierno
recurría la emisión monetaria esto es el
Banco Central la gente enseguida corría
a cambiar sus pesos por dólares ante lo
que pudiera pasar lo que hacía más
difícil mantener el tipo de cambio al
tiempo que se reducían las reservas de
Divisas las cosas iban de mal en peor
Ya solo quedaba esperar el estallido de
la crisis
la explosión
[Música]
los argentinos sabían que la situación
era de extrema gravedad entre enero y
noviembre de 2001 los depósitos
bancarios cayeron en otros 20 mil
millones de pesos el equivalente a
20.000 millones de dólares de ellos
1.500 millones fueron retirado de los
bancos el viernes 30 de noviembre era un
ritmo insostenible Así que en la
solución del gobierno fue decretar un
feriado bancario y restringir el retiro
de dinero de las cajas de ahorro y
cuentas corrientes la medida se anunció
el sábado 1 de diciembre y comenzó a
regir el lunes 3 se estableció un límite
de retiro de 250 pesos semanales por
cuenta bancaria es decir que si uno
tenía 10.000 pesos en su cuenta del
banco Solo podía acceder a 250 por
semana Y ojo porque luego se redujo a
dos el número máximo de cuentas
bancarias que una persona podía tener
apunte el resto del dinero se podía
utilizar por medio de tarjetas de débito
u operaciones electrónicas pero claro
Tenemos que tener en cuenta que a
finales del 2001 era muy poca la gente
que realizaba ese tipo de operaciones en
Argentina Esto fue el corralito un
corralito que según lo ha probado por el
gobierno tendría una vigencia de 90 días
Claro que esos tres meses fueron
suficientes para cambiar la historia del
país y causar un daño económico
imparable
la medida provocó el efecto opuesto al
que perseguía el gobierno en lugar de
generar tranquilidad generó
incertidumbre caos la medida hundió el
consumo y a muchas pequeñas empresas
Pero además los argentinos empezaban a
comprender lo que suponía perder sus
ahorros de un día para otro pues porque
el fin de la convertibilidad uno a uno
con el dólar iba a suponer
irremediablemente una tremenda
devaluación del peso argentino de ahí la
urgencia por sacar el dinero os acabas
tus ahorros o los perdías y como el
gobierno no te dejaba sacarlo era una
especie de ruina cámara lenta
el gobierno en ese momento buscó el
rescate del fmi pero cuando kava lo
viajó a Estados Unidos se encontró con
una respuesta bajante que no que no que
no nos contéis películas sin ordenéis
las cuentas públicas y recortáis el
gasto Público de una puñetera vez
nosotros el fmi no vamos a poner más
dinero de ninguna manera ni de broma
pronto la situación degeneró a tal nivel
que la desesperación lo saqueos los
choques con la policía se hicieron
cotidianos finalmente el 19 de diciembre
el presidente del arroba ante la
imposibilidad de contener las protestas
y los saqueos decretó el estado de sitio
y el mismo instrumento del que se habían
valido las diferentes dictaduras
militares de la Argentina para controlar
a la población supuso arrojar gasolina
al fuego y tan solo un día más tarde el
20 de diciembre los enfrentamientos con
las fuerzas del orden dejaron 29
fallecidos el gobierno estaba acabado
minutos antes de las 20 horas el
presidente presentó su renuncia y se
alejó de la casa rosada en un
helicóptero
[Música]
dolor y ruina
desde la rúa el poder pasó a Ramón
puerta luego tres días después la
asamblea legislativa eligió presidente
al gobernador de la provincia de San
Luis Adolfo Rodríguez o sea quien Por
cierto ostentó el cargo apenas siete
días antes de renunciar desde el 23 al
30 de diciembre periodo que aprovechó
Eso sí para declarar el default de la
deuda externa ante la aplauso un anime
de todo el congreso Qué felicidad luego
el poder cayó en manos de Eduardo
caamaño y finalmente en Eduardo dujalde
un sindicado que había alentado las
protestas y que asumió el cargo el 1 de
enero del 2002 en menos de 10 días
amigos la Argentina tuvo cinco jefes de
estado diferentes fueron las horas más
negras del país durante los siguientes
meses la pobreza se multiplicó el peso
se siguió evaluando y pasó de uno a uno
a uno tres los depósitos no se
devolvieron a los que tenían dólares en
el banco se los robaron y se los
cambiaron por pesos que cada vez valía
menos y por supuesto todo esto supuso el
fin del peso y del sistema financiero
argentino nadie en su sano juicio
volvería a dejar sus ahorros en manos de
los políticos de este país
Y qué queréis que os diga razones no
faltaban de hecho la historia parece
Clara desde entonces las cosas no han
mejorado mucho 20 años después Argentina
sigue en las mismas el país está más
endeudado que nunca tiene la mayor
presión impositiva de esa historia y la
inflación anual supera el 50 por ciento
es lo que ya se conoce como la tragedia
Argentina pero amigos llegado hasta aquí
turno para ti y en esta ocasión voy a
ser crudo y directo crees que la
Argentina tiene solución déjanos tu
respuesta por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabes si este vídeo te
resultó interesante No olvides darle a
like y suscribirte a visualpolitik y hoy
en especial un abrazo muy fuerte a todos
los que nos veis desde ese país que a
pesar de todo sigue siendo tan
maravilloso la Argentina
[Música]